Okay, so what we have here, again, is pseudocode for
our K-NN algorithm. And I'm sort of writing it as
like, a function. So, you're going to be given some
training data D, that's the little x, y points, x
y one, x y 2, x y 3, so on
and so fourth. You're given some kind of distance metric
or similarity function. And this is important because this represents
the domain knowledge as I think we, we've already said.
You get some number of neighbors that you care about,
k, hence the k and n, which also, by the
way, represents domain knowledge. Tells you something about how many
neighbors you think you should have. And then are given
some particular new query point and I want to output
some kind of answer, some label, some value. So the
K nn algorithm is remarkably simple given these things you
simply find a set of nearest neighbors such that they
are the K closest to your query point.
>> Okay. I'm sort of processing this. So the, the data
the capital D. Are those pairs and there's a set of pairs?
>> Yes.
>> Ok. And k smallest distances. So this NN this is a set?
>> And it consists of all the elements in
the data that are closest to the query point?
>> Yep. And the so the query point is a parameter of that. Okay.
Yeah. Alright. I think I. Oh. And then it's, then the so it's just return.
>> Yeah, so we haven't figured out what
to return. So there's two separate cases we've been
talking about so far. One is where, we're doing
classification, and one is where we're doing regression. So,
a question for you would be, what do you
think we should when we're doing classification? Sort of,
what we were doing before on the map. What
will be a way of returning a proper label?
>> So you want to
label, not a, like a weight on a label or something like that?
>> No. I want a label. You have to
produce an answer. You have to commit to something Michael.
>> Alright. Can I commit to more than one thing?
>> Nope.
>> Okay. So I would say that a reasonable thing to do
there would be. Did we get Ys associated with the things in NN?
>> Yeap.
>> So I would go with they should vote.
>> I like that. I think that's a good one,
so we'll simply vote and what does it mean to vote?
>> It means, let's see, so feel like there would be a way to represent
it in terms of NN, the set. Like do you want me to write it formally?
>> No.
>> Oh, then I would just say The closest point.
Whichever yi is most frequent among the closest points wins.
>> Yeah. Right. So you want to find a,
a vote of basically a vote of the yi's,
that are apart of the neighborhood set. And you take the plurality.
>> Plurality I see. So it's whichever one occurs the most.
>> Right.
>> What if there's ties?
>> It's the mode. The mode. Right.
>> Right.
>> Mmmm. I love mode.
>> What if they're ties? That's a good point. Well, if they are
ties among the output, then you're just going to have to pick one.
>> OK.
>> And there's lots of ways you might do that.
You might say, well, I'll take the one. That is
say, most commonly represented in the data
period. Or I'll just randomly pick each
time, or any number of ways you might, you c an imagine doing that.
>> The one that's first alphabetically.
>> The one that's first lexicographically?
>> Hm.
>> What about in the regression case?
>> Okay. So in the regression case our y-is are numbers.
>> Uh-huh. And we have the closest Yi's, so
we have a bunch of those numbers and it
seems like [LAUGH] if you have a pile of numbers and have to return
one, a standard thing to do would be to take the average, or the mean.
>> Yeah. Now let's just simply take the mean
of the Yi's, and at least there, you don't
have to worry about a tie. That's right. Though,
I guess, you know. We didn't really deal with
the question of what happens if there's more than
k small. It's, like, what if they're all exactly
the same distance? All n of them are exactly
the same distance. So which are the k closest?
>> Well, there's lots
of things you could do there. I guess what I would suggest doing, is,
take the, If you have more than k that are close, that are closest
because you have a bunch of ties, in terms of the distance. Just take
all of them. Get the smallest number greater than or equal to k. Okay.
>> That seem reasonable?
>> Yeah, I think that's what college rankings do.
>> Actually, that is what college rankings do, and then they, yeah,
that's exactly what college rankings do. So, let's do that. We know
that college rankings make sense. [LAUGH]. Yeah,
those are, they're scientifically proven to be,
>> Youths.
>> scary, scary to people in colleges.
>> That's exactly right. So, here's what we've
got, Michael. So, all we do is we take
the training data. We have some notion of
similarity or distance. We have a notion of the
number of neighbors that we care about. We
have a query point, we find the K closest
to one, you know breaking ties accordingly. And then
we basically average in some way, in a way
that make sense for classification, in a way they make sense
for regression and we are done. It's a very simple algorithm,
but some of that's because a lot of decisions are being
left up to the designer. The distance metric. The number k,
how you're going to break ties. Exactly how you choose to implement
voting. Exactly how you choose to implement the mean or the
average operation that shows how to do here. And you could
put a bunch of different things here and you end up in,
completely, you could end up with completely different answer. Mm.
>> By the way, one thing that you might do, just to give
you an example of just, how much range there is here. Is rather than
doing a simple vote by counting, you could do a vote that is say,
weighted by how far away you are. So we could have a weighted vote.
>> Uh-huh.
>> That might help us with ties.
>> That could help with ties. Yeah.
>> You could do a weighted average. Yes, right.
So, you're basically saying that the y values that correspond to x values that
are closer to the query point have more of an influence on the mean.
>> Which makes some sense, right?
>> No, I think it makes a lot of sense!
>> So, how would you weight that? What would you do?
>> I would weight it by the similarity.
>> Right, so well in this case, the similarity is we have a distance value
similarity, so You would have to, you know, weight it by something like one over
the distance.
>> Oh I see. Okay. That seems like a hack.
>> Sure but it's a hack that sort of makes sense.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So anyway. Simple algorithim. Lots
and lots of decisions to make here. All
of which could in principle have a pretty big effect. And so, in order to see
that, I want to do two quizzes that I hope get to heart of this and
maybe give us a little bit of insight
into how some of these decisions might matter
on the one hand, and exactly just how simple
or not simple this algorithm turns out to be. Okay?
>> Awesome.